slurpee slurpee yeah i know bro but you
know honestly we're able to talk
we're able to talk her away you know i
was able to hear how she how she
that guy and i was like what the [ __ ]
did you say what the [ __ ]
did you just say to me what the [ __ ]
was that did i hear what what i heard
okay so like my big [ __ ] guy
all right this is a tinder song we're
kind of new into this polyamorous thing
what my [ __ ] [ __ ] guy
all right we're doing this polyamorous
thing you're you're having the time of
your life bro
you're enjoying it how's the polyamorous
life for you i feel a lot of resentment
flat out i'm a [ __ ] i i've been a shitty
guy but you know i've kind of grown
and been in be like yeah this is what i
did wrong and i'll be back
can you can you let them in bro i'm
sorry
go ahead all right she wanted another
dude
and then what happened so she [ __ ]
another dude she told me
afterwards and i was like oh and then
she was on some [ __ ] when you try to
[ __ ] another broad
yeah but i didn't yeah and i told you to
get rid of her [ __ ] out of here you told
me to mean
stand up you told me to [ __ ] man up
that's what it that's what you told me
bro
go on
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah so he told you to get rid of
her
and you didn't so keep on going no
honestly bro it's my [ __ ] birthday
like tomorrow
and this check you know she's been
giving me a lot of [ __ ] about you know
but on
okay okay hold up hold up so after that
[ __ ] that i told you
you know she was like i don't feel
comfortable about you seeing this other
chick
you know i canceled it the first time i
canceled it the first time because it
was like you know what
and i really care about this girl i care
about her feelings
no it's because you're being simply yeah
man she's trying to have her cake and
eat it too she want to be in a
polyamorous relationship
while keeping you monogamous
bars okay i'm gonna stop you right there
i'm gonna stop you right there
are you guys in a polyamorous or open
relationship or not yes
okay then then then she need to get with
the [ __ ] program
okay yeah i mean i don't know it's not
like you guys are in a monogamous
relationship
and she cheated and then now you want to
choose it's an open relationship
you guys both agree to the terms so you
should be able to do your thing
i don't get it yeah yeah and so i told
you last time you put your foot down and
you go bang that other bra and she got
something to say that she take a hike
because she's the one who's breaking the
terms of your agreement
yeah did you act like a little [ __ ]
when she [ __ ] some other dude
no so then so then she needs to put on
her big girl panties
and she needs to get with the [ __ ]
program my advice is not changed
so tomorrow's your birthday so after you
get some cake
get some good dessert all right and by
dessert i may get some good tuna
and you do your thing that's it what you
mean it's not a discussion
she don't go to saying this
i'm just saying bro i respect how this
female feels you know i
i see you bro man this is
oh we're not doing this no sir we're not
no
i don't understand why people accept
these kind of relationships where
there's rules for me but not rules for
you
you can go out and do whatever you want
but what
huh who nah bro
y'all agreed to polyamorous relationship
she went
polyamory it was your turn to go
pollinate
[Music]
you don't care about our feelings you
just don't respect your own boundaries
it's like being in a relationship with
somebody who's not in a relationship
with you and be like oh
well i respect this girl like i want to
be with her well she doesn't want to be
with you she's not in a relationship
with you
like what is you doing
i'm sorry you guys have to witness this
maybe you don't want to be a simp maybe
you're worried
that you're going to turn out to be a
simple and that's why personal
self-development is absolutely necessary
that's why i want to thank today's
sponsor are you dead
no oh okay i'll be up yeah do you think
how often is it
you got the author man
you you know what you know why i laugh
cause i was about to tell you you used
that word too much
sim and then [ __ ]
this is simpy
i really don't use that word too much i
know but i've been hearing that [ __ ] for
so long that i'm like you know what this
is a simple
oh my god bro
it gets worse you want to hear him sit
more oh let's go
now you got me interested let's go let's
hear the scene ah jesus [ __ ] crazy
here we go three no no
no no no no
you you can't you you're getting cucked
right now that's crazy bro
how's she getting some side dick you're
getting cooked in a polyamorous
relationship
that's new levels yeah
you're getting cocked
in a polyamorous you know what broth i
don't often do that
but you called her a [ __ ] but
the [ __ ] is you
that's new levels i'm on a new level
okay okay okay i don't want to trigger
you i want a date
i want on the date and it went [ __ ]
good
i didn't bang her because i didn't want
a banger bro i just wanted to get to
know this female dude i can't be that
one
dude who's the the polyamorous [ __ ] was
not his idea
he just said yes because he likes the
girl that's it that was not your idea
that was not your plan you said yes
because
let's find out like oh yeah let's have a
really good day i'm a really good
[ __ ] guy let's [ __ ] [ __ ] out with
the first date no [ __ ] that
no [ __ ] i need to be emotionally
entangled as jada says it to [ __ ] be
with this person because that's how i
[ __ ] work you know
yeah emotions are a [ __ ] thing for me
and you know i care about the way she
feels and i listen to her and you know i
just wanted to prove that you know i can
go on this date with this other [ __ ]
girl
and not [ __ ] you know [ __ ] have to
[ __ ]
plow bro bro bro bro i don't care if you
have to fall in love with the [ __ ] the
[ __ ]
i don't care that's what a polyamorous
relationship is you literally have a
relationship
where you guys encourage loving other
people
yes yeah
yeah so
that's the whole point of your
relationship yeah
so if she got a problem with that that's
her problem
because she didn't have a problem with
it when she was building a bond with
another dude and slurping on his dick
slurpee slurpee yeah i know bro but you
know honestly we're able to talk
we're able to talk her away you know i
was able to hear how she how she
that guy and i was like what the [ __ ]
did you say
what the [ __ ] did you just say to me
what the f was that
did i hear what i heard
[Music]
i had to hear
how she [ __ ] that dude
how can you be cocked
in a polyamorous relationship
you heard about how the guy [ __ ]
your girl which by the way she's not
your girl
she's everybody girl yeah
she's my girl now and now when it's time
for you to do that
you said no but more so you're like i'm
gonna prove to her
that i'm not i'm not gonna you you said
so many conflicting things
we're in a polarized relationship and
then you're gonna call her a [ __ ]
no you agreed don't call her [ __ ] don't
call her that
second thing you're gonna be like oh you
know what i'm gonna go on a whole date
and i'm gonna prove to that girl that
i'm able to go with that girl
to be with that girl without having to
engage with her
why would you do such a thing why do you
need to prove that
she's already [ __ ] why aren't you
because you don't feel like doing
like [ __ ] that's fine if you don't
feel like [ __ ] you don't feel like
[ __ ] but
that was not your rules you accepted
something that you did not agree with
but you agree with her more than you
agree with what you're trying to say to
you
that's it listen violating your own
boundaries does not make you a good man
makes you a weak man i think you're
you're thinking like
i'm doing all this thing for her and i'm
being considerate and i'm letting her
beat me it doesn't make you a good
person makes you weak
bro i'm sorry you can't that that
there's a lack of respect there
even if she loves you in certain ways
even if she does some good things for
you even if you love certain aspects of
that relationship there's a certain
measure of respect that has to be
maintained
she had a full-on side thing and she did
her thing and now she's trying to tell
you can't have your cake
huh nah i don't play that no no it is i
totally agree i totally agree but you
know after
all that i cancelled the first date
because of what she said and she said
she was uncomfortable and i was like
okay but you know because of what you
said
when i first asked you this question i
actually i listened to you and i was
like you know what i canceled it but you
know what [ __ ] it i'm gonna i'm gonna
reschedule it be like hey
lost class you know you know what people
ask you for advice don't ever call again
you know people ask you for advice don't
ever call again but they not asking for
advice no
that's exactly this don't ever call
again bro
don't don't ever call again you're a
lost cause and you just want people to
say
yeah you're right no you're not amen and
you want to be right
somebody get my man out of the sim zone
get him out of the sunken place
all right pull another movie get out
okay but for dudes are getting cooked in
polyamorous relationships please
all right getting cooked in polyamorous
yes that is a new level
get macaulay culkin he'll be the main
actor okay you're getting cocked in a
polyamorous
skin [ __ ] up to the polyamorous
relationship you know what you call call
that movie
home alone
all right so you know it's just
fine other people like you call that
omalum too
that's crazy that is crazy
that that makes guys don't be don't
don't don't simply like this all right
and i hope this guy he realized he's
gonna realize it eventually he's like
how stupid was i
you know in that relationship that i let
somebody walk over me like that
you know it's fine if you're a young kid
you know that happens every now and then
but if you're a grown man it's like bro
you gotta grow up hey vivela doormat
jesus christ man that that that's that's
that's
that's new levels
[Music]
play
no time for fake ones
[Music]
that keeps